playing that i spent three days no four
days playing just four days playing jump
king yeah how was how was that
experience hell yeah
it looked like it well i was enjoying
myself in my own space you were being
ridiculed by tens of thousands of people
i know yeah
yeah it was tough it's tough it's really
like soul destroying yeah i don't know
it's a really good game though i want to
play it it's i don't know how to
describe it it's like when when kelly
was on and talking to us about it i
don't think you can appreciate this game
and how difficult it is until you'd play
it yeah i i certainly didn't because
looking at it it looks so simple yeah it
looks easy yeah it looks so simple how
can it be to just jump into this jump
stream like how hard can it be to like
judge the jump but then you're like oh
okay well the only
instinct that gives you like you you
cannot see any indication of how long
this jump is going to be other than your
muscle memory yeah how long you hold the
space bar or controller and how long are
you going to jump and it is soul
crushing because there are some jumps
where it's like it is like a pixel
perfect yeah there's like a one one
tenth of a millisecond window where you
have to get it right
and if you [ __ ] it up you have to go
back and do 50 plus perfect jumps to get
to the opportunity to [ __ ] that one up
again right which will probably [ __ ] up
again so it's really soul-destroying and
uh yeah the first game i beat it um i
did it in one eight hour stream
which was long but it was fun because
you know i left uh text-to-speech things
on yeah so people were just insulting me
they were like connor you can't stream
uh you can't you can't keep streaming
this you'll get a dmc for streaming
white men can't jump
and stuff like that and they were like
they were like connor just turn your
monitor upside down you'll be making
good progress
like that just insulting me and it was
really fun i think it made for a really
good stream yeah and then i decided um
because cali said that i should that she
think i could do the the dlc yeah and i
regret doing the dlc the dlc was so yeah
i i remember you finishing the original
jump king in like one one day and
everyone's like celebrating i was like
good for you because i remember tuning
in in the morning and tuning in the
night and i'm just like connor's still
[ __ ] honest
and he was like finally you've done it
and then when i when i saw kelly told
you to do the dlc as well i was like oh
so it's just a little extra that will
take like half extra bonus an extra
bonus stage that would take half the
time and i remember tuning in one day
you were doing it tuning in the next day
you were still doing it
i was like damn this guy really likes
this game that's cruel man the dlc is so
much harder than their base game so i
think i don't know how many people have
beaten the base game but i know that
only two percent of people who have it
on steam beat the second dlc yeah and
there's a third dlc which is even harder
which i'm too afraid to attempt didn't
ludwig be like all three of them in like
an hour or something yeah logic's insane
yeah i think ludwig's first run of it
though did take 40 hours of the last dlc
[ __ ] hell so just like just different
man
he's crazy though he is insane and like
you can't appreciate these games and how
good ludwig is at them until you do them
yourself and you're like this is
insanity yeah like this is insane like
the sheer amount of muscle memory
required for this game is just absurd
it's just like like a from software game
right it's like
that level muscle memory if you're dying
dark souls you go back to the spawn
point right which can be far but yeah in
this game it's like you can lose like
two hours of progress like no
checkpoints anywhere right no so and the
the base game there's points where you
can get to where you're kind of safe you
can't fall too far but the second dlc
there's points where like you can fall
massively right yeah and there's never
any safe points and yeah in the third
one again there's another even
harsher jump and it's just brutal i
recommend trying it i don't know why
it's kind of i want to try it yeah i
want to try it as well although
you know there's rage games there's like
not not like getting over it but like
you know there's like cat mario games
back in the day oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah well they were just like troll yeah
it was like it was just [ __ ] with you
this game was
uh
it feels like you never blame the game
when you fail like it's like it's always
you like you're the one who didn't do it
right yeah you never feel like you were
unfairly played there are some sneaky
things they do here yeah but
it's a very rewarding experience however
i do not want to do it again for a long
time
i had horrible anxiety on the last day
because i was getting to the end yeah
and i just wanted it to be [ __ ] over
with yeah so i was so close and if i
fell i would go all the way back down
yeah it's just horrible i think my heart
rate was like resting at like 110 or
something because it was just it's
nerve-wracking because you know if you
[ __ ] up this one jump you've got to redo
it for three hours yeah so there's one
point during the dlc on the second day
where about halfway through the stream
i'd gotten to the final part right and i
was like oh my god somehow like i was
stuck on this one stage for hours and
then i just started going through all
the stages perfectly and i was on the
very last stage and i was like oh my god
i'm gonna do it like my heart is like
120. i'm like [ __ ] holding the space
bar and then i do one big [ __ ] up and i
lose like uh half the progress i've made
and i couldn't and the rest of the
stream i couldn't get back to where i
was right and i was just so miserable i
went to bed just so sad i was like this
is horrible i just couldn't do it i
couldn't do it i'm a fake gamer i
couldn't do why would you do that to
yourself
because that that
fantastic twitch content people love
watching a man go insane
of course
you know i don't know why anyone would
ever play those games
just for fun
yeah i was gonna ask would you ever
consider playing a game like this if you
didn't stream it absolutely
no you couldn't why would you do because
there's absolutely no reason to do it
right if i do it on twitch it's like
okay well it's great content people it's
really easy to understand you know you
play 13 sentinels it's like yeah hey so
here's the 15 characters you need to
know all the in-depth law about by the
way most 10 seconds of dialogue that
changes everything yeah yeah jumping
it's like my mom can understand it yeah
if you fall that's bad you're a kid who
jumps you literally go up and if you
fall you can sometimes fall really fast
yeah yeah and that's bad you know it's
super easy to get people invested in
yeah and uh yeah it's just fun watching
someone go insane i think i don't know i
would never do it off-stream yeah of
course ever why would you i don't
understand why people have done it
what what compels you to keep going i
what compelled me to say satisfaction
yeah right what compelled me to keep
going is that i don't want people call
me a little [ __ ] for quitting right so
i was like i got a cute guy everyone's
gonna call me a little [ __ ]
basically and i also i'm very stubborn
so
oh yeah yeah oh kelly's still going cali
is still going right now is that the
third dlc uh yeah yeah but i mean by the
time this has gone out i'm sure callie's
beating it right i'm sure
let's hope so
hopefully i'm hoping he's insane kelly
also is like insane in it cali beat the
base game in like an eight minute speed
run very insane holy [ __ ] yeah really
good stuff really insane [ __ ] you now
again i'm i'm much more appreciation for
anyone who's beat that game now
would you ever consider speed running
yeah i was about to ask would you ever
watch
the base game
easy mode now like that's there's only a
few jumps that scare me in the bass one
right the rest of it's like super easy
because there's like there's margin of
error because like if the platform's
wider you can obviously yeah yeah but
sometimes they do like just like a
little pole yeah and you have literally
like you have to get the ark perfect
right right and sometimes there's ice on
this the platform so you can fall off or
they're rounded so it just sounds like
those like really punishing like nes and
like super nintendo games yeah i feel
that's like kind of becoming a trend
again especially in the game yeah d
world i feel like i'd feel like but
sometimes those nes games are just
[ __ ] oh yeah they were like unfair i
feel like this was
an experience that is very challenging
but also very rewarding weirdly yeah
like i've never felt more accomplished
about a video game yeah i i felt that
when i streamed uh hollow knight
a while back like that game is like
[ __ ] unforgiving and so yeah and to
this day i haven't beaten it just
because this is one boss where i'm just
like this is [ __ ] right right those
are the types of games when you beat it
you're just like yeah when you beat it's
like [ __ ] yeah let's go yeah yeah i
don't know it i feel like i learned a
lot about myself in those 30 hours
i learned an awful lot about me and who
i am by just i mean you kind of have to
right
you play a game like that for that long
which i don't know how the [ __ ] you do
respect to you for being a true gamer
yeah i can't even play not a gamer i
can't even play a game that has like
more than five inputs for like more than
three hours you know [ __ ] just just
pressing one space bar and just jumping
for like 10 hours i can't [ __ ] i was
sweating playing 13 cinders and you
literally just press circle
i'm sure i'm getting i'm pretty sure i'm
getting repetitive strain injury
repetitive um
rsi rsi rsi i was pretty sure i was
getting that after a while because i was
like
it's my number yeah yeah it's good
though i really do recommend trying it
yeah i definitely want to stream it just
uh you should i really want to we should
race through it yeah you guys should do
a stream we should race it i'll
commentate this yeah it's stressful no
no because if you no one expects you i
don't want to do it on my own
the first time you want to you want me
to suffer with you joey i don't want to
be alone by myself with chat just
[ __ ] doing this right
i want someone to be there with would
love that people would love that you've
got to do this now this is a brilliant
idea yeah come on let's do it
yes god do
don't say you're gonna beat it just say
like you're just gonna play it and see
what happens and because now if i play
i'm going to beat it
that's that's the thing right if i start
if if i start
i'm saying it if i start then that's my
commitment well now i can't [ __ ] do
it with you because i have to i know you
don't have to you don't no you don't
you can do it you know what mama didn't
raise no quitter
mama didn't raise the baby
she raised someone who's so afraid of
failure that if you don't start someone
you don't need to quit you're gonna play
it you're gonna play it both
oh my god
but no like uh yeah i mean it looked
fun i guess
big air quotations and fun like you
completing it looked fun i didn't i
didn't like see it didn't look fun it
looked satisfying it looks satisfying
it's very satisfying yeah it's got a
good soundtrack too